Speaker 1: All right.
I don't want to spend a lot of time on this,
but I do want to show you just a couple of
other clips.
You know, yesterday I played a part of a very
strange interview where right wing actor Jon
Voight, who seems pretty scrambled himself.
I must say Jon Voight was interviewing Trump
and Voight started weeping about how good
of a person Donald Trump is.
We now have more clips from this truly bizarre
interview and in this clip.
During this Jon Voight interview, Donald Trump
tosses a word salad that I can't even describe
as a chop chop.
It's more of like a confetti.
Just it's confetti is all it is.
Check this out.
Speaker 4: It had to be, you know, approached
and changed.
You took that on and you made it into a great
golf course.
Right.
And I think it's one of the most.
Speaker 1: Donald Trump's heroic golf course
restoration is incredibly impressive to Jon
Voight.
Speaker 4: Asthmatic golf courses in the country
now Doral because of you.
So I have that to thank you.
Thank you, Mr. President.
I'm I'm just very grateful for your presence
in so many areas.
But first of all, I think it's so nice the
way you express that and even the slight little
tears that come.
You're just a fantastic person.
And I really want people to come together.
I want the United States to be one in there.
Speaker 1: By the way.
TRUMP He loves that people cry over how great
he is.
That's what Trump does, that he loves the
tears that Jon Voight shared over how great
Trump is.
Speaker 4: Understanding of the greatness
of this country and wanting its future to
be magnificent for the new generations to
come.
Right.
And and that means the world will go toward
peace.
So I. I say to the folks, I say, let's stay
and hope.
Let's appreciate our country and let's appreciate
those who are capable of turning the tide
and bringing us back to the greatness that
we were given by our founding fathers.
Well, I want to thank you.
And we love the country.
The country is in trouble.
It's got to be solved fairly quickly.
Yes, there is no choice but to solve the problem.
But it's a big problem.
It's a big problem.
And I hope it continues forward.
And we love Israel and we hope everything's
going to be okay.
But a lot of good moves have to be made or
it's not going to be okay.
We say God bless you and good luck to you
and thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
Thank you very much for this time, Mr. President.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
What an unhinged and disjointed word salad.
Just attempting to throw bouquets at each
other, but kind of failing.
Here's I played a short part of this clip
yesterday where Jon Voight cries over how
great Trump is.
Here's a little bit of a longer a bit of context
on that.
Speaker 4: And they tell a story.
You one went into the place and you in check
on that place.
And whenever somebody you come anywhere.
Everybody says he knows everyone who works
in every one of his facilities.
And I know you have places all over the country.
You went in the place.
He said, Is Sally So-and-so working here today?
He went in and said, Yeah, she's never come
see me.
And you went to one of the offices and she
came in and you said, I hear you have a little
bit of a difficult.
And she said, well, I have some cancer issues
and.
So I'm getting emotional.
This is from you.
You keep saying the champ.
You can watch the champ without crying.
Well, I can't.
I can't just go through the story without
crying.
And you said I'll take care of.
Let me take care of the.
The.
Whatever it's going to cost.
You know what?
I'll take care of you.
You're valuable to me.
Whatever that is.
I mean.
And that's who you are.
Speaker 1: By the way, I know that Voight
doesn't necessarily mean it in a literal sense,
but you're valuable to me.
That's exactly the theme of how Trump sees
his own supporters.
I've told you all this before.
Trump cares about his supporters to the extent
that they're useful to him, even though really
they're the folks that he's spent his entire
rich life trying to not be around.
And this is all just so bonkers.
I've tried to research this.
I was not able to find any evidence that Trump
paid for anyone's cancer treatment.
I saw on video that Trump made fun of a disabled
reporter that we all saw that we know took
place.
We saw the video.
This story about Trump paid for someone's
cancer treatment.
I was able to find no proof
of it.